[Music]
uh hello everyone this is Grandmaster
Victor michalevsky for St Louis chess
club and today in the grand Masters
Choice uh I'll continue showing some
beautiful ideas from my own games we're
gonna see fragments of the games and
also the games in full
so the first position is on the board
it's black to move
it looks like a regular end game
position
black is upper Pawn but white is
attacking both the Knight on the four
and Pawn on C4
okay if you have any ideas
let me know
it's black to move Faron
okay let me show you
the first move is Knight B5 check
okay that's right Knight B5 of course if
the King goes back to D2 we can even
trade pawns on B3 and black
keeps an extra Pawn
so the principal move is to go to B4
and this is still a double attack on
Boss B5 and C4
so what do you do next
so back to D4 and what what if white
comes back to C3 with the King
okay any any ideas
so Bishop E4 F takes e496 and E5 Maybe
the move is a little unexpected
so Alex should I show it or
go for it
okay it's C takes B3
the night sacrifice
yeah it doesn't seem to work in the
beginning right
so
okay King takes B5
now B2
and Rook B1 so what was the point
the pawn is stopped and white is upper
piece
Aaron says Rook to C1 but then just
stroke takes B2
between
here yeah in both cases I mean white
keeps his extra piece right after boss
Rock City and Group B
that's right Bishop to E6
the pawn is not really hanging at the
moment
and black has a threat of Bishop takes
A2
uh in the game white tried to give up
the night with Night series is
definitely doesn't help White
and if white plays something like say
King to B4
bringing the king closer and creating a
threat of Rook text B2 now I cannot take
the A2 Pawn still Rook takes B2 but I
can just play Rook to C2 attacking the
bishop on G2
and if the bishop moves
then just Bishop takes A2 and
black is winning
and if he plays King A3 attacking the
opponent protecting A2
then black can simply take and
here black should be able to win with an
extra Pawn
in the game white played Knight C3 and
just lost this position quickly
and black is winning
okay next game
this was the game against the
international Master uh rabinovich from
Israel
I played with the white pieces and it's
white to move in this position
I I believe it was this love defense
so there is a suggestion to take on G7
and after King takes
rook g1s and back to h8
foreign
also says Rook takes G7 but but what's a
follow-up after black takes
okay so there is a suggestion of playing
Knight F6
okay another suggestion C6
so after Rook takes G7 King takes G7
caparini says Rook G1 check but then Kim
goes back to h8
please give me the entire line because
I'm not sure you're giving the you are
giving some moves but I don't know at
what point you want to play it
okay Khalil suggested C6 followed by B5
then take the Knight and then the Rook
takes G stuff
okay
but how does it help to exchange the
Knight on D7
Aaron says Knight G5
but in this case even Bishop takes G5
and
there is no attack
so a precise move folder is needed in
this position
uh Bishop to D3 uh yes that's a possible
move
D3 followed by Knight to F6 followed by
Knight F6 it's not a bad idea but black
can start with the move G6
first attacking the queen and only then
taking something let's say taking on E3
so Bishop this three G6 attacking the
queen yes and then Knight takes easy
Knight takes F6 it takes F6 Bishop takes
F6
and Bishop D3
so when do you play all of this
so if you start let's say with the move
Knight F6
black intake e takes Bishop takes bishop
d3s and black has a move G6
protecting H7 and attacking the queen at
the same time
so this idea doesn't work
caprini says after Rook takes G7
okay
so after Rook takes G7 play Knight F6 so
Rook takes G7 King takes G7 let's see it
on the board
and then play Knight F6
and then Knight takes he takes Bishop
takes Bishop D3 but that's still not a
Checkmate right that's a threat of a
checkmate but black can consider
something like Rook h8 for instance
and the game is not over yet
all right so let's go back
Mill says Rook to G5 but after Rook
takes G5 black doesn't even have to take
the Rook he can take the bishop on E3
for instance
so it's not going to work
okay caparini says Rook takes G7 then
Rook takes G1 check let's see if it
takes and then check
the King goes to h8
and probably now the idea was to play
Knight two
F6
and that's not not a bad idea
let's see I feel that the black may
still have some defense
for instance black intake
it takes and now let's say Rook to jid
if you play Bishop D3 now
zero can probably go to G6
would it work
let's have a look I'm not sure
so let's say if white takes with
zerokins and Bishop creating a threat of
a Checkmate then black can move the
bishop away from E7 something like
Bishop takes F6 for instance
and black is doing fine
so
once again the precise move folder is
needed
okay what if you take
root take G7 then the next Rook come
over and then you play Knight to G
yeah that's a G5
yeah so playing Rook G1 and Zen Knight
G5
so you do create a thread of a Checkmate
but black is going to take
right if you take with the queens and
Rook G8 again
now Bishop to D3 okay but then black is
probably gonna play F5
to just block the diagonal because if
you're taking poisson the Knight is
coming
into defense
yeah it was close but
not yet the checkmate
yeah
so but Rook takes G7 is a correct move
it's just after King G7 you need to
combine the ideas you had
so the ideas of Knight F6 and Rook G1 so
how do we combine those ideas
okay so
let me play
okay RK mule says Bishop D3
um Bishop D3 might be possible but I
don't think that's the best move
because black can play even Rook to h8
and the Kink will try to run
Issa Khalid says C6
is ready Maybe
C6 is possible but it probably doesn't
change that much
yeah The Rook is still hanging indeed
the bishop is still hanging
yeah we need to create some immediate
threats
first Cameo says Rook G1 Kim gaichi and
Zen Bishop D3
but in all these cases we need to
consider the move F5
which blocks the diagonal when you take
this upon the Knight takes and then if
Knight takes Bishop takes and the queen
protects H7 at the end
when do you want to play Queen to H6
oh here
all right away okay an interesting idea
but your Bishop is also under attacks
you will be you will be unable to give a
check right I mean you can give a check
but your Bishop is thinking
now we play Knight F6 that's a correct
move
so Knight takes
Now Pawn takes with a check
it's important that we
take the Knight with a check Bishop
takes back
and now
yeah Rook to G1 check now and when the
king gets to each it now we play Bishop
D3 so now the F Pawn is blocked
no F5 ideas
and the only defense would be
sacrificing the queen
yeah but it's not going to save black of
course black can try to take but first
of all white is already up a lot of
material and even something like Bishop
H7 can work and just
Queen H5 and black gets checkmated
so if we look from the very beginning
the idea is the first sacrifice The Rook
then to block the F Pawn with the temple
creating a thread of a checkmate
it's very important so black has no time
for anything he has to take than we take
with the check
they have to take then we give a check
forcing the king to h8 if we start with
Bishop D3 black and play Rook to h8 and
the King escapes
so we need to give another check first
Kim Gachet and only then Bishop to D3
and then there is no defense
okay next next example
I'll show this game in full that's my
game against
Indian Grandmaster Hare Krishna
one of the top players
the game was played in Gibraltar
Festival
I played with the white pieces
so it was a fan Kettle system against
the king's Indian
he played the line with the Knight on D7
Knight c35 E4 so white takes the center
it takes Knight takes
rookie
rookie one
it's a little bit more common to start
with H3 and then rookie one but it
shouldn't change much because the game
just transports to the same position
and now black played A5 which in my
opinion is slightly inaccurate
a little bit better to start with Bishop
D7
is this
so a disadvantage of the image that A5
is the option of Knight D2 B5
so this way uh why they stopping C6 idea
which is typical for this system
now the move is impossible because the
D6 Pawn is hanging
but black still played Bishop D7
which answered with Bishop to F4
and now black committed a mistake he
played Queen to C8
yeah instead black could try to take the
Knight on B5 but after C takes White's
position is better
but what's wrong with screen seed
foreign
to take Bishop takes D6 but just C takes
yeah but you're giving up two pieces
right for The Rook so I don't know if it
it gives much for white
might be even better for black
oh okay
Knight to D6 he takes
it with the bishop
yeah yeah but that's kind of slow no no
no
why Bishop will be hanging after you
capture
yeah no that's right okay another
suggestion is by caparini to play Knight
xc7
okay then Queen takes
I mean
okay hurricane also says Knight takes C7
but what's a follow-up
s
so when do you push the pawn
so so Knight C7 Queen C7
there is a suggestion to take on D6 yeah
Bishop D6
uh now let's say the queen goes back to
see it
now
is this I can't play this with the
numbers is this six the fifth ring yeah
okay
so Muhammad says after Queen said Bishop
takes C5 but then just Queen takes C5
like after you take with the bishop on
D6 Queen seed
and then take on C5 but Queen takes back
still Knight takes C7 is the correct
move so let's see Knight takes Queen
takes Bishop takes D6 and did Queen seed
and now indeed you push the pawn first
before taking the Knight on C5 because
if you trade pieces first then E5 is
already impossible black can just take
right so you start with the move E5
now the Knight moves away Knight to H5
and then you just capture the knights
that's right Bishop C5 because if the
queen recaptures you can get the bishop
and so in this position black played
Knight takes G3 a nice move
so if you take the knights and he takes
on C5 with the check and you get no time
to get the bishop
yeah nitro3 is a nice idea
all right Muhammad just remove water but
it can change a lot
so what should I do now
well I need to do some participation
okay
there is a suggestion of Bishop D6 and
that's exactly what was played in the
game
so why just saves the bishop right
uh White is up opponent at the moment
and the Knight goes back to H5 no
Knight to F5
yeah that's also possible in fact
this time I can probably play let me see
probably I can go Knight D5
because there are threats of Knight B6
Knight C7 if you trade on D6 and later
even Knight E7 check
so for instance if you take the C4 pawns
and Knight B6 I suppose
with some Forks
okay
so uh in the game he played Knight H5
which is not a bad idea because now the
Knight wants to get to F4
and create some threads
and another idea is to just capture the
H3 Pawn of course
so white has to be careful
okay there is a suggestion of playing
Kim gauge 2 but then Knight F4
Rook Leaf Rook to E3 I mean yeah you you
can go with the Rook to E3 but I don't
want to allow Knight takes G2
yeah he takes the bishop oh okay
oh whatever
I mean when the Night Comes to F4 later
the night exhibition
D5 yeah that's right so exactly that's
what I played Knight to D5
putting the knight in the middle you see
ascends the Knight is really good there
but blacken takes H3 Pawn right
all right so
so now the material on the board is
equal
yeah the idea indeed is still uh to play
Knight to B6
the queen goes to F5
so black wants to create some shreds
against my kink
so something like Bishop G2 King G2
Knight F4 check might be very unpleasant
idea
and that would probably happen if I took
zero cure on it
like Queen F3 you mean
yes sir uh Queen F3 is possible but then
probably his Rook can escape right like
Queen F3 let's see no not a bad move
but he can try probably to trade and
probably save this Rook
may maybe Rook to I don't know Rook to
A7 to keep the B7 Pawn not the best
Square for the root but at least a 7
Pawn is protected
might still be good for white so but
yeah at least the material is equal
yeah I I wanted to win some material
okay Muhammad says Bishop takes H3
indeed that's a move
Bishop takes Queen takes and then
and then the Rook leave that's right now
rookie 3 The Rook comes with a Tempo
attacking the queen
so the queen goes back to H4
that's right now it's safe to take the
look
so 98 Rook takes eight
okay why this happened exchange but the
king is still not very safe
right the Knight still wants to come to
F4
with some threads
also Bishop H6 might be one of the ideas
Queen to D3 but you get under Knight F4
again
Pawn to E6 so to open your Bishop you
mean
okay interesting
yeah probably also possible but I assume
black is just gonna take after E6 right
Queen D5 that's right
that's the move the queen is really good
in the center control in this diagonal
and also attacking B7
yeah that's right it doesn't stop the
night from coming to F4 but let's say
after Knight F4
uh let me see what was the idea the idea
was the time covering the G2 Square so I
can even take and if they play any check
like this King F1 no problem
there is no Queen G2 no Queen H3 right
I'm covering the key squares
the so the queen is really good in this
diagonal
yeah so after they move Queen to D5
black played through kid bringing the
Rook into play
yeah that's a good idea to bring the
other Rook into the game
and indeed I played through k31
a black played Queen G4 check
ing F1 and now Rook to E6 because he was
afraid that I'm going to push the epon
and he was afraid for a reason right
so he put the Rook on E6
if I capture the pawn he can capture my
C4 Pawn right with the check
first yeah that's what I did I did
something about this bomb
uh so it's either there's a between
so if you just push what is that B2 then
it's protected yeah B3 you're right
that's what I did exactly
yeah so just protected the point he
doesn't have any immediate threat
I'm protecting the opponent wanna take
B7 why not
he played Bishop to H6 attacking my Rook
and you play Rook to F3 if I play Rook
to F series and Knight F4 is still
possible
again some thread
okay
I still have to be precise
right here if you just take the power
that's right that's what they did Queen
takes B7 because the Rook is untouchable
if he takes the Rook a check
King G7 and queen f8 checkmate
yeah so Queen takes B7 he had to come
back with the Rook Rook to E8 to cover
the back ring
my Rook is still hanging
E6 you're right yeah now it's time to
push the E Pawn so E6 he has no time to
take my route because he just take F7
obviously so he took F takes E6
now okay
so
okay there is a suggestion to take on E6
tonight on F4 a rook F3 probably is not
bad as well but Rook takes E6 this was
which was which was suggested in the
chat is correct indeed I can take
yeah we're gonna see first of all black
gave a check on H3
to see where my Akin goes
yeah if I play Queen G2 it's in fact
possible then he plays Queen D3 check
King G1
exchange unit 6 and at the end white
should still win but I decided to start
with King G1 avoiding this idea
and now in case of Queen G4 check I'll
just block with the queen and no more
checks
so he had to try Rook takes E6 nothing
else he can do
so what queen did the Kim goes to F7 to
protect the Rook
G7 Queen D7 check indeed
so King F6
checks
indeed indeed and now Bishop E7 check
yeah yeah everyone in the chat also
saying Bishop E7
so the king cannot go up to F5 because
of Queen takes E6 obviously
and uh so he he just resigned here
because if he goes back to F7
I can play a bishop deed
the King goes back and I simply take the
look
he's down in exchange and his King is
also open
so no real chances in this position
or if he takes on E7
if I take the queens and Rook takes E1
check and he gets a lot of pieces
so I take zero quiz a check second goes
to F5
check on E6 yeah it's cure and we get
the queen
Okay so
yeah thank you so after Bishop E7 Hare
Krishna resigned
okay another
interesting game
I played uh in the European Club cup
against a strong player from Czech
Republic Victor laznichka
I play it again with the white pieces
this time started with C4 C6 and then D4
D5
The Exchange variation of this love and
the move Bishop G5
which is kinda rare in this position
so black played
H6
thank you
Bishop H4 and queen to B6
that's a very logical idea because black
and pins his EPO
and attacks the B2 Pawn as well
Knight C3 white sacrifice is a pawn
because if Queen takes B2 we want to
take on D5
so there is a question what's the idea
behind the move Bishop G5
right so if we go back a couple of moves
so the idea is first of all two pins the
pawn on E7 and also to meet the the move
Knight F6 with Bishop takes F6
right so it just makes Black's
development a little difficult
okay so after H6 Bishop H4 Queen B6 I
played Knight C3
and he he went for the most principled
option Queen takes video anyway
he is accepting the challenge
Knight takes D5 and now E6
so he's ready to uh kind of sacrifice
The Rook but it's not really a sacrifice
if I play Knight C7
the king comes to D7 what's going on
do we have a problem with the connection
the Knight is just going back and
doesn't let me play nights yourself
yeah because it's a blunder probably
yeah
that's why I'm not allowed to do it
that's weird
let's try to reload
okay
oh no
no way you cannot play a bad move like
that
maybe check me
how do you want to do it
oh Queen A4 check yeah but he doesn't
have to block on D7 he can block on C6
or B5
yeah probably Knight C6 is the best
because if you block with the B Pawn
then Queen takes maybe check and takes
right but yeah the problem with Knight
C7 check obviously is King D7 Knight tx8
and Bishop B4 and you get checkmated
yeah so that's why that's why I wasn't
allowed even to play Knight C7 it's too
bad right
yeah so white should start with Rook B1
because this way The Rook is covering
the before Square
as the queen goes to A3
and now uh Queen to C2
Knight C7 is still not the best idea
but you see now it's better so I'm
allowed to play it King D7 Knight takes
eight Bishop B4 check Rook takes Queen
takes Queen D2
and then black and repeat moves
that's probably a draw
so uh White starts with queen C2 in
another intermediate move attacking the
bishop on C this time
and black played the correct move Queen
2 A5 check
so that's a check and he is also
covering the C7 square with the queen
if he starts with Knight A6 instead
white can try E4
and the idea is that if black takes the
Knight we have not good again
not a good move
Bishop B5 check
then we trade Bishops and take on B7
with the check
and black gets under a very strong
attack
so Queen A5 check a better move
and then we can either transpose to the
game with King D1 or play Queen C3
with some interesting end game
yeah yeah but the queen is also under
attack right so he gets no time
yes this was a classical game
okay so Queen A5 check was played
now the King goes to D1
so zero conceit is still hanging so he
gets no time to take my knight
and so he played Knight to A6
covering the C7 Square still the best
move
it's not good to go to C6 because of
Rook to B5
a very nice move
and The Rook is Untouchable in view of
Knight C7 and if the queen goes to A3
still Knight C7 check
the queen
well the major sports
uh if the queen goes that way I mean
yeah yeah but I I mean if the queen goes
this way
no I mean if his Knight ah If he if his
Knight takes the uh Pawn
yeah
then uh
that's in fact an option maybe in this
position but we can just take the yeah
you're right we can take the queen and
then give a check and take the Rook yeah
you're right
yes yes so he played Knight A6 the
correct move
still E4
same idea again
so if if black plays
it takes D5
it's not a bad move by the way
it can play Bishop B5 Bishop D7 we trade
Bishops Rook takes B7 and a lot of
complications
it's still a playable position for black
but looks very scary especially if you
don't know this position to go for
something like this over the board
and so my opponent decided it's better
to just cover the diagonal with the move
Bishop to D7
but in fact he missed something here
it was a miscalculation on his part but
also on mine as you guys
yeah first of all Bishop takes A6 of
course he saw this move
right he cannot take back obviously
because of Knight C7
but his idea was to play Rook seed he
can also take the Knight you're right
and that was already his only move
to take the Knight but then I can play
Bishop takes B7 Rook beat and even the
simple Knight F3 and
it's a very dangerous position for black
okay
yeah but he played Rook to see that was
his idea basically he thought he'll
first attack my queen on zente
exhibition
and here white has a winning idea
which I missed during the game as well
there's something
okay okay
oh oh okay you sacked your queen and
check with the white Bishop in fact
that's what they did in the game but
that's not the best
okay RK Mall says Rook to B5
and that's indeed the winning move
Rook to B5
yeah but Rook B5 is really nice
so what is black going to do now
if you play let's say queen takes A6
then just Queen takes a check
Bishop takes Knight C7 check and white
simply wins the queen and white is up on
Exchange
so if black takes a queen Rook takes C2
we simply take Rook takes A5
and now it turns out black doesn't have
any good Square on the C file
so let's say 0 goes to C6 for instance
well C8 doesn't doesn't really matter
think in any after any of them again
this these two moves are not allowed
in any case we're gonna take with the
bishop and
The Rook is under attack after they take
the Knight we take the rook and
white is up on Exchange again
and there are no other squares just C6
and Seed
and if the Rook goes somewhere else and
Knight C7 Checkmate of course
yeah
yeah and finally if the queen goes to A3
after Rook B5 white can just play Knight
C7 check
Rook takes Queen takes Queen A4 check
and the simple Rook to B3
and white is completely winning
see to me this is the hardest part about
chess if somebody would have told you
that there's a winning move yeah well
that's a good point yeah
yeah if I knew that there is a winning
move I would find it but right
yeah I just didn't know it
yes yes
of course you can sense it because the
position looks like there might be
something right
and so in the game I thought that
something is Queen takes seed
and that was a wrong move
Queen takes it
yeah looks like a good move indeed
Bishop D7 takes takes Rook takes B7
check I thought it looks promising
and he played King 2 E8
in fact if he played King seed he could
even set some problems for white
objectively probably it's equal but
white would have to find some
ideas here king bed Bishop G3
preparing a discovered attack
on A4
King to E1
that's the only move by the way
the King goes to it then check check
and now white sacrifices his Knight on
D5 this Knight is just
refuses to move from D5
so it takes 95 check the King goes to D6
check on G6
a lot of mess here
King goes to D7 Knight takes f8 check
now King C6 and now a funny part
a quiet move King D2
threatening Rook C1 checkmate
almost Checkmate right getting the queen
check
King C2 Knight E7
okay that's computer's line of course
Rook C1
Rook takes f8
Rook takes a fade
now a brilliant move King to D7
Rook takes F7 King to eat
Rook F4 G5
zero goes back D takes E4 The Rook
escapes Knight to D5
King B1 A5 and now black is still better
and so why it still has to be curved
after all of this
yeah so in fact the move King C8 offered
black winning chances but he went back
to it
and we just repeated the moves
and the game ended in a draw
yeah yeah
it's short but interesting game I think
thank you
okay
yeah this this was a classical
song
okay thanks everyone for watching
no problem no no problem
yeah in fact Tuesday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday lectures at this time
yeah say the same time yeah same time
now now you know
so see hope to see you all tomorrow same
time
okay
so bye for now
[Music]
foreign